[Music]
good morning
everybody there we go welcome my name is
Dave bernes I'm a senior devops Advocate
at GitHub and we've got a workshop for
GitHub co-pilot today uh start out with
very basic basic stuff see how it works
with different languages get a taste for
uh generating code asking questions
about code uh and and a lot of things
like that and give you resources that
you can take away with you to even dive
in and learn more and do more uh
afterwards uh so with us today we have
Christina senior developer Advocate from
GitHub and Harold principal product
manager on the uh co-pilot and visual
studio or code team right so yeah
they'll be helping us as as Proctors and
and
everything all right so first we'll do a
little overview of co-pilot how many
have used GitHub co-pilot
before okay so a few of you had so this
yeah this will be starting out kind of
basic but we also tried to be pretty
comprehensive so hope hopefully you'll
see something that you haven't seen yet
uh before here we'll talk about how to
set up and access the co-pilot we're
leveraging code spaces so you don't have
to worry about having Visual Studio or
jet brains or anything installed like
that uh point to the resources and
everything then get into the labs and
we'd love to get your feedback on
co-pilot and how this lab went and and
everything so um here's the link to get
access uh GH .io aiare Workshop or you
can take a snapshot of that uh QR code
to get access and that should take you
to a
repo
for there we go
see where is my window here we
go hi I'm Christopher I'm a senior
Enterprise Advocate at GitHub and I want
to talk today about GitHub co-pilot and
how it helps me as a developer you see I
became a developer because the job
seemed like it was an awful lot of fun
and often times it is but there's also
an awful lot of tedm what I want to be
able to do is solve the big problems and
come up with unique Solutions but what I
really find myself doing a lot is
writing boilerplate code dealing with
obscure syntax and having to learn an
awful lot of new languages and
Frameworks co-pilot can eliminate the
repetition it can help keep me in the
Flow by reducing the number of times
that I have to leave my IDE to go look
something up so how does it do this
magic well let's take a look I have here
a python Django application Andy python
Jango is a great web framework that's
built for creating front ends to backend
databases the first thing that I need is
a model and this can be repetitive code
so using natural language I can describe
what I want I can say create a
model called speaker with name email and
Linkedin URL and now we get some gray
italicized text that is my code
suggestion from co-pilot it's suggesting
this class speaker I hit tab to accept
it and then I notice an entire class
suggestion from co-pilot all based on
that one sentence comment I hit tab to
accept and now that's been built for me
now how does GitHub copilot make its
magic happen well it's based on a
training model that consists of billions
of lines of publicly available code and
text that allows it to synthesize that
natural language comment into a code
suggestion it's also able to make
suggestions that follow best practices
it's a very common best practice in D
Jango for example to override the string
function so that way we can get a string
representation of an instance of an
object and sure enough in that
suggestion that co-pilot made it went
ahead and included that we also notice
that Copilot is able to read my code and
make suggestions based on that so it
gives me a suggestion down below of a
brand new comment to create a talk model
because it saw that I had a speaker it
goes hey wait a minute you've got this
speaker they probably need to do
something here's a talk for you and I
can Loop through a couple of different
suggestions that it might be making
based on what it sees and then hit tab
to accept so I'm going to accept that
comment I hit return hit tab to accept
the next part and then hit tab to accept
the entire class that it's now generated
for me one of the other big places where
co-pilot shines in keeping me in the
zone is helping to reduce the number of
times that I have to go look up some bit
of syntax I generally speaking can get
around regular Expressions but quite
frequently I need to go look up that
syntax but with c pilot I can just stay
in the flow I can describe one more time
in natural language what it is that I
want let's say I want to add on a code
field with a pattern of three
uppercase letters a
dash and three digits and co-pilot
actually even suggested the rest of the
way because it saw what it was that I
was trying to do and I hit return and
now co-pilot will make a suggestion for
me of a regular expression so I didn't
have to go look up that syntax co-pilot
did that for me right here get up
co-pilot Works across languages and
Frameworks we've already seen how it can
help us out with a python Django app but
what about say c and a web API app well
I have a model and validator and data
context already set up and I want to now
create a controller a controller that
typically involves an awful lot of
tedious boiler plate code well I can
just code like I normally would I'll add
in my speaker
controller I will begin to import in the
appropriate namespace so we'll say using
and then Microsoft ASP net core MVC
which you'll notice that co-pilot is
suggesting it's also suggesting my nty
framework core and now I need to go grab
my data model so I'll say
using conference. data and then now what
you're going to notice is that co-pilot
takes over the rest from here it sets up
my namespace for me it adds in the
appropriate attribute for API controller
and sets up the route and then generates
the entire controller for me I wrote
maybe about a line and a quarter worth
of code and it took care of the rest for
me now when you see that gallicized text
you might be thinking gosh that looks an
awful a lot like intellisense and you
might then be wondering well what's the
difference between intellisense and
co-pilot well intellisense is wonderful
at making small suggestions it can help
remind me what the name of a variable is
or help Point me at a particular method
but it does require that I get a big
part of the way there that I'm already
starting to write my code but with
co-pilot I was able to say in natural
language this is what I want and get an
entire class suggested for me something
which intellisense isn't able to do you
also might be wondering well what about
chat GPT and chat GPT is a fantastic
external tool but it's going to lack
context co-pilot knew that I was
creating a Jango application and the
code suggestion that it made was based
on that that if we notice with our
speaker class it inherits from models.
model which is exactly what we want with
a d Jango class if I was using chat GPT
I would have to go to this external tool
I would have to describe the entire
scenario the Frameworks that I'm using
eventually get a code suggestion that I
would then have to copy and paste over
to here co-pilot meets me right where I
am and in the tools that I'm already
using if you're using visual studio
Visual Studio code jet brains or neovim
there's a Plugin or extension that's
available to you for GitHub co-pilot and
you might be wondering does co-pilot
obviate developers is it going to
obviate my job and the answer is no you
still need to have a developer co-pilot
does not generate perfect code you'll
notice in my example here that when it
created the reference between my talk
and my speaker it set it such that if we
delete a speaker that has a talk it's
going to delete all of their talks
that's probably not what I want so I can
go back and make the update to that code
to ensure that that's now going to be
protected so that's going to block a
speaker from being deleted if they have
a talk so I can modify all of the code
that it generates and I want to make
sure that I still review it I also want
to ensure that it goes through all of
the standard checks that I have for code
that I wrote or anybody else wrote
that's going to be committed into our
code base this includes our security
checks code quality checks linting Etc
co-pilot is a co-pilot not a pilot and
what co-pilot will do is allow me as a
developer to focus in on the bigger
picture and so if we bring it back to my
code one last time here and let's say I
want to register all of those objects
all of those classes that I made with
the admin page I can come over to my
admin pi and notice that co-pilot based
on all of its training data based on its
sense of my context starts suggesting
the code that I need so I didn't even
need to add in any comments I didn't
need to write any code and co-pilot made
all of those suggestions for me and we
see this reflected in the survey data
that we get back from developers that
have access to GitHub co-pilot for
business
73% report improve job satisfaction and
87% report a reduction in repetitive
code get up co-pilot also just reduces
the amount of all up code that I have to
write by up to
46% and improves productivity by up to
55% of all the things giup co-pilot for
business can do what it can't do is
replace your role as a software creator
if you want to start playing around with
co-pilot you can check out that URL on
the screen which will bring you to a
curated environment where you can
explore the magic of of GitHub co-pilot
for
yourself actually that's why we're here
today we're going to be doing uh little
different lab than what was presented
there but uh so comments
questions thoughts after seeing that
video co-pilot service does some work to
ensure that for all that context that
it's pulling in you know it's not
grabbing any email addresses or uh
GitHub handles or anything like that so
that when it goes to the open AI large
language models you can guarantee that
we're we're not sharing any personal
information or anything like that this
is one of the advantages of using GitHub
copilot in this closed loop like this
over copying and pasting back and forth
between chat GPT itself so then we're
using or using the large language models
there to generate code and those large
language models have been trained on the
vast majority of the open source code uh
that's out there uh and then it when it
as it comes back for suggestions you
know we we do a little bit of processing
there to make sure that those
suggestions don't include code that
could lead to a security vulnerability
like a SQL injection or something like
that um and you and typically there's
going to be multiple suggestions that
come back so you have the option to look
through those multiple suggestions and
and you'll see how to do that in the
lab all right so
um you know some common questions we get
does co-pilot train on my code no it
doesn't you can pull in your code for
context but it does not train on your
code so you can be assured and your your
Enterprise your company can be assured
that your code is not somehow magically
going out there and being used by others
uh what included in the context includes
the file you're working on the tabs that
are open in the IDE starting with the
current file um so yeah you can help
feed co-pilot more context by being
conscious of the other tabs that you
have open uh can I just write the code
on my own as developers yeah we write an
awful lot of boring code but so
offloading some of that repetitive stuff
like the model classes and generating
unit tests and all that
allows us to spend more time thinking
about the big picture right less time
getting frustrated on oh what's the
Syntax for you know for this type of a
thing in in Python you know co-pilot's
going to give you working code almost
all the time so you know you can focus
on the bigger picture on
things oh yes
helpa yes it can help with refactoring
there's ways you can and actually
getting into copilot chat is a great way
to look at this because with with chat I
can select pieces of code and then I can
say explain that code to me or propose a
fix or make the code more robust more
secure you know can I can I simplify
that code so yeah that that's one way to
look at uh refactoring and things if my
project has hundreds of files and I want
appro suggestions does that mean that I
have to see get co-pilot by opening all
the tabs for all the relevant stuff
um yes but I don't know that you would
need to open a 100 files right yeah yeah
I I need actually say here's the stuff
you got to pay attention to yes
otherwise you'll miss on the important
yes yes and that's definitely something
to and I I think we've got yeah we do
have a scenario in here where you you'll
kind of you'll kind of see that in
action and just in a very simple world
but this is where you know you probably
want to kind of play around with it a
little bit right as you're using it you
know start using it and and just try
with no other files open and then open
the model classes or uh the controllers
or or whatever you know that's related
to it and and just experiment and see
does it get better and better and things
like that so on that point um you have
any guidance on how to think about
what's to much
get B down like you know this context
yeah yeah yeah um I
don't I don't know of any specific
guidance um on anything like that when
Harold comes back I think Harold had to
take a call that'd be a great question
for Harold when he comes back in the
room so hold on to that
thought all right other comments
questions okay and yeah this actually
kind of got ahead of ourselves here
that's this is what we talk about with
prompt crafting you know knowing how
to what one thing I always say is you
know you don't want to just say co-pilot
give me a function you want to say
co-pilot I'm using such and such a
framework given inputs a b and c I need
a function to calculate X you you want
to be very specific in your uh comments
because then you're you're giving
co-pilot
the needed context and everything so uh
yeah all the information needed to help
provide co-pilot to understand the task
better uh make sure that the specific
goal or purpose you have in mind when
creating a prompt we talk about even
starting out in a new file at the top of
the file put a good block of comments
that say hey what's my overall intent
here what you know what libraries in
that do I intend to use because that
will feed into the context used by
co-pilot uh yeah being very clear in
your requests uh and things and being
very specific is important in prompt
crafting and we'll look at that a little
bit there's also some resources at the
end where you know you can learn more
about prompt crafting uh and everything
so um yes you want to use good rather
than just using variable names A B C you
want to use descriptive variable names
descriptive function names uh and things
like that that really helps co-pilot
understand your intent um you know
follow strong principles when creating
named blocks and things like that like I
said spell out variable names be
consistent uh you know because that'll
help copilot understand and focus in on
the context and things and if at first
you don't succeed iterate
Christopher had an example in there the
speaker class was generated and then it
was going to allow speakers to be
deleted even if speakers had talks
assigned to them but we don't want that
right so he went in there and changed
that and I've seen him I've seen him do
do that in another way too rather than
manually making the edit he just deleted
that line and added another comment and
said hey don't allow speakers to be
deleted if exist and then it generated
uh the line that he needed so just as
you would with an per programmer sitting
right next to you have a conversation
with GitHub co-pilot and iterate through
to get exactly what you need um even
providing examples when it comes to
especially things like test data and
whatever if you're generating tests that
gives co-pilot more and more
context keep files open that are
relevant we you know we've talked about
this so this is just a a good view um of
that uh you know what I'll do is I I
don't have it there right now but I'll
I'll create a PDF of this presentation
and I'll put that out there as another
file in the repo that I'll put I'll put
it in right now awesome thank
you so yeah you'll you'll have all these
tips uh and everything uh with with you
and you can refer back to them even as
you're working through this then um so
yeah co-pilot looks at tabs formality
isn't required uh you know the
co-pilot's not going to scold you for
bad grammar or anything like that and
surprisingly co-pilot's actually very
tolerant of like misspellings and and
things it can figure out if one word in
a sentence is misspelled from the rest
of the context of the sentence it can
still figure out your intent uh and
there isn't one right way to use
co-pilot and I you know I think that
goes even with with programming right if
if everybody was given the same
assignment here it would vary uh with
each and every person uh kind of a thing
whoops so yes above all else go with the
flow
[Music]